We all have tens of thousands of images stored
in our computer in this day and age.
Here’re some images from my own personal
collection, the ones that I took on a holiday
to the northern part of Australia a few years
ago. There are pictures of water lilies, birds,
trees, sunsets, Aboriginal rock art, and crocodiles.
Every image in this collection is stored in
an individual file in the file system of my
computer. Let’s select this particular crocodile
image here and we can see which file it is
in. This is a Mac, so I come up here and I
will look at the file in the Mac’s file
browser utility called Finder. Under Linux,
Windows, there are equivalent applications.
And here we can see the particular file that
holds that crocodile image. We can see that
it has a .JPG extension, that means it is
a JPEG image and we will talk about what that
means shortly, and we can see that it is 3.7
megabytes long.
Now we can open that image in the regular
image browser on the Mac, and in this case
it is the application called Preview. There
we see the crocodile looming large on the
screen. And we can zoom into this image and
as we zoom in we see that the image becomes
more and more block-like. And as we zoom right
in we can see that the image is made up of
these tiny little blocks. These are the smallest
elements within the picture. We call them
pixels, that’s short for picture elements.
So what you are seeing here are individual
pixels that comprise this particular image.
Let’s go back to where we were.
For each particular image, as well as the
data that comprises the image itself, the
pixels that make up the picture, there is
a bunch of additional information which is
referred to as metadata. And we can look at
the metadata for this image by clicking this
button here. Now, the metadata is displayed
up in the top corner, and there is quite a
bit of it. First of all, we can see the model
number of the camera that took these pictures.
We can see the resolution of the image and
that is that the image is 3248 pixels wide
by 2160 pixels tall. We can see that the image
is 3.7 megabytes long on the disk. We can
see the focal length or the zoom setting that
I used when I took this particular picture.
I can see the F-stop or aperture setting.
And I can also see the exposure time or shutter
time when I took this particular picture.
More modern cameras would have additional
metadata, for things like the GPS coordinate
of the place where the image was captured.
There are many, many different types of image
format commonly used today. If you go and
look on Wikipedia, you can find that there
are hundreds of different types of image file
format. I have listed here just a few of the
most common ones. JPEG are format files which
typically have a file extension of .jpg or
.jpeg. TIFF files, GIF files, Portable network
graphics or PNG files, and many others. When
we actually look inside an image file, it
has really three separate components, and
they live within what we call a container.
So here we have an empty container. And one
of the first elements in the container is
what is called the header, and the header
contains information about how big the image
is, how wide it is, how tall it is and the
type of compression, and the type of pixel
format. Is it eight bits per pixel, ten bits
per pixel or whatever.
The next object in the container is what is
called the metadata, and that has information
about the actual picture that was taken. It
might have the GPS coordinate of the camera
when the picture was taken. It might have
the F number and the focal length, and whether
the flash fired or not. So it is information
about that particular picture that was taken.
And then, finally we have the actual pixel
data itself, the information which represents
the image and it may be compressed or not
compressed.
So when we talk about image file format, we
need to actually talk about two things. We
need to talk about the particular container
that holds this information and there are
different types of containers. And we also
need to talk about the different compression
methods which are applied to the image pixel
data.
So when we commonly talk about a JPEG file,
JPEG format file, correctly we should be saying
that this is an EXIF container that holds
JPEG compressed image data.